Right before I did my special,
my closing did I do on the show on the special,
the closing bit.
I uh,
I was sat with you for a fucking hour in the back room cause I took it up in the
main room following like Deleah and I just said,
here we go.
And I,
man,
that club can really let you know where the silence is.
And you go,
all right.
And then you're like,
oh,
I've been lazy.
I've been performing the fans who will give you the benefit of the doubt and
they want you to succeed.
But when you do a Netflix special,
you need it to be to strangers need to like it.
That's the,
the old Louis quote that I used to hang my hat on,
they were like,
why don't you work at UCB?
And he goes,
anyone can make them laugh.
He was like,
I'm famous,
like get,
they've had go in.
Like that's like making your friends laugh.
That's why this is why I do the road is the art form is to make strangers laugh.
And I was like,
yeah,
it is to make strangers laugh.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also,
you don't want a delusional perspective.
And one thing that does happen to some complex Stan hope was it was by it.
Like,
he's like,
why would I go and do someone else's audience?
He goes,
it took me 25 years to make my own audience.
I'm like,
okay,
I get it.
Yeah.
But I really feel like to develop material to really do it right,
you got to do it in front of just regular people,
people that aren't necessarily there to see you.
And the beautiful thing about the stores,
if there's 15 people in the lineup or 20 people in the lineup,
whatever it is,
how many of there see you?
10% 30% 20% like,
you know,
maybe they're there to see you and to Leah and also,
Tom and also Christina,
like it's,
they're just comedy fans do that.
Bert Kreischer fans.
Yeah.
That,
that's giant as giant.
Because those guys that like develop like that.
I've,
I've seen a few people that develop an audience and that's all their audience
and there's,
they just get real complacent,
real lazy.
That's the um,
those,
it,
I mean I I've,
I said lightly because there's some internet comics meaning like youtube
comment,
people that do comedy now and some are good,
some are good and some are developing.
I don't know.
I wasn't saying that to be polite but like,
but that one guy,
he got booed off stage and Montreal because he's been performing to fans.
Oh well here's the other thing about that guy.
That guy goes up on a show where there's all these other comedians on and then
at the end of his sat says that comedy shouldn't be about about preaching.
It should be about making people laugh,
right?
It shouldn't be about ethics or morals,
sexuality or race,
sexuality or race.
It should be about making people laugh.
People pay to forget about that stuff.
Bitch,
you are on stage not making people laugh.
That is what you're doing.
You silly.
Fuck it is one of the silliest things I've ever seen in my life.
It's like this is an,
he's essentially a beginning comic,
open,
open Mike.
He's maybe been doing stand up three years.
So he does like videos and the videos are very popular and they're funny.
Yeah.
If you're from the south,
they're really funny just unless someone's doing your shit,
unless they're stealing or stealing from somebody else,
just do your fucking act.
Unless something happened before you that's so agregious and ridiculous that you
feel like you have to address it when you go on stage because it's his sitting
in the room.
Yeah.
And to just try to do ever notice,
you know,
when you pick up your phone,
if you just try to do that and everybody's like,
what the fuck you not going to address,
which has happened.
Sometimes you have to address what just happened.
Like sometimes someone will go on before you and just eat so much shit that you
have to say something.
You have to say something you have to.
But what that guy did was ridiculous to tell someone what comedy is and what
isn't.
I'd said I had read an article about that.
This,
uh,
I'm assuming she's a gay woman,
wrote about like trashing Hannah Gatsby and going,
hey,
we're gay and we're doing standup comedy.
We're not,
we're not just preaching,
we're doing standup comedy,
talking about trauma and it's working.
You just don't see us.
So don't write us off and say comedy is dead because you don't see us.
I don't think Hannah Gadsby saying comedies dead.
I think journalists are saying comedies dead,
and I think we're all buying into it because these people were writing these
articles.
They're not even in comedy there just comedy fans or fans of her and what I
think she did,
and I'm only seeing part of it,
I saw the whole thing.
I'll tell you right now,
let me have one joke.
I like a lot,
but it's whatever she did is fine.
Yeah.
Thing.
It's her artwork.
This is what she's doing.
It's fine.
Like it's,
it's,
if people enjoy it,
that's great.
But the problem with comedy is the comedy is one category.
It's just comedy.
But comedy could be Cat Stevens,
it could be guns and roses.
It could be the Geto boys.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like when you go to see music,
there's a very distinct genres.
There's no,
there's just comedy.
Comedy has just comedy.
Like you could go see a folk singer and what they're doing on stage,
like really slow and quiet is music,
but then you go to see fucking led Zeppelin and you go,
okay,
well that's music to how the fuck is that music too?
You know how,
how has the motley crew the same kind of thing as cat power?
How is that?
How are they,
how are they the same?
Well,
they are both music.
Just like we do comedy and she's doing a version of comedy.
Some of it is really funny and some of it is her just talking about stuff and
like a very serious way.
That's fine.
Yeah,
that we're not against each other.
This is what's crazy.
Everybody is like,
you know,
this is deconstructing comedy.
Comedy is dead now.
Like what are you talking about?
That's crazy.
We know she's doing what she's doing.
If you enjoy it and that's what you want to see more of,
go see that.
Yeah,
that's what she does.
That's great.
She has a great joke about Unicorns that I,
I giggle about once a week and I'll tell her jokes.
It's not on Netflix.
You can see that when I was growing up,
I knew more facts about unicorns and I did lesbians.
She goes,
there are no facts about unicorns.
I was just like,
that's a good fucking,
that's a good fucking joke.
That is good joke.
Yeah.
I mean that's her experience,
right?
She's a lesbian.
It's hard.
It's hard out there for a pimp.
I get it.
It's fucking like where we are.
I think people create unnecessary and artificial adversaries.
I really do.
And I think this is one of the ones that's going on right now in comedy and I
see it all the time with this and the net thing,
it's like stop,
stop,
stop with the art.
I mean I,
I fall into it too.
I buy a new two and I read some of these articles like comedy's not dead.
The fuck are you talking about?
It doesn't make any sense.
You read the article and you start thinking,
she said it like the way that,
exactly.
You're like,
oh,
she's telling us I can't do comedy anymore.
She didn't say she just did something and someone interpreted it that way.
And if she says she can't do comedy anymore,
that's fine too.
Yeah.
She could just do like now she's famous,
right?
She could just do one woman specials or one person's specials or one entity
specials.
How we are framing it.
I wouldn't say it,
Joe,
can I say the gender would be even,
I would be like,
she does a thing.